[Music]
hello ladies and gentlemen
on tuesday yeah we're pretty sleepy
because we went out last
night last night yeah it was fun yeah it
was fun it was actually a really good
night i saw a lot of people we hadn't
seen in a really long time
yeah you know it was kind of dead but
yeah but not too bad i mean considering
yeah they were quite there were more
people out than i expected to be out
you know what i mean so yeah it was a
good time but yeah we're kind of sleepy
we're only we're doing an hour late
because well
you you had to go like on the grocery
run and it just took longer than
you thought it would run down yeah we've
got all our
two or three months worth of food
you know so we always have like extra
[ __ ] it's like six hundred dollars worth
of meat
yeah lot of food this is why we're fat
but um now if i bought six hundred
dollars worth of [ __ ] sugar and
carbohydrates and even fatter
that's true yeah it wasn't it wasn't six
hundred dollars worth of meat
oh both well it was a lot of meat yeah
you bought fruit and vegetables and
coffee yeah
and cat treats yeah you know a new pan
new fry pan new frying pansy there you
go it wasn't all meat
it was a 40 frying pan was it hopefully
it works out better than some of them
what happened to your other big one you
don't like that one so much
non-stick the non-stick surface on it
got burnt i can't stand non-stick [ __ ]
but i can't find professional stuff i
gotta i gotta
do a deep dive online i just want
regular stainless yeah you can order
that kind of stuff it's just it's
expensive if you
if you pay for it you know yeah it's
like you know a good pads go you know
[ __ ] 100 something dollars
yeah it is yeah well it's just like good
knives it's just like anything else you
get
[ __ ] get that copper [ __ ] man it's
[ __ ] like several hundred dollars for
a good
good yeah copper pan and that's just
like they don't sell that stuff because
most people don't
use it they don't know what they're
doing well they don't really need it
like you don't need professional [ __ ]
most of the time and if the pans are
cheap it's like oh they wear out you
just throw it away and buy another one
you know cooking in copper
versus like steel or aluminum this crap
that they'll [ __ ] say there's there's
no comparison
yeah copper just [ __ ] cooks so well
copper and cast iron
yeah well yeah i think i got you get
that cast iron
that large one we've had that for ages
we make a little
problem i need something cast iron
that's all you know huge
you like the big man and then that's
like several hundred bucks yeah i just
you know i just gotta bite the bullet
and find it i don't remember how much
that one was i think it was
over a hundred yeah i think it was 120
or something like that and that's like
the kind of big one
like a little bitty one too but big
enough for like a medium-sized pan pizza
yeah because we made pancakes in it
before all right
so the movie we're talking about today
this was a good one you guys i really
really really i'm gonna tell you that
right now i really really really like
this movie
um it's actually it's it's kind of more
a comedy than a horror movie although
it's got like i mean
you know it's built as a horror comedy
it's got a lot of gore in it
because it's uh a werewolf movie
obviously because it's called the wolf
of snow hollow
but i've seen it described this is
actually a pretty um
this is actually a pretty accurate
description i've seen it described as
if david fincher made fargo
um which that's pretty that's pretty
accurate
i've also seen it called like fargo meet
silence of the lambs
or something like that but maybe like a
little bit funnier than that implies it
definitely has that
quirky coen brothers kind of sense of
humor
to it which i really really liked so
this is the second film
by jim cummings who is a
who's writer and director and he's uh
stars in this as well
as the main character john marshall and
i think his first movie was called
thunder road and i've heard that one's
good too but i haven't seen it so i
can't really like
say but a lot of people have uh said
this one was a little bit better
but so this is set in like this dinky
little town
in utah like up in the mountains and
it's the winter time
and uh it's kind of one of those ones
where there's all these cops and they're
kind of like
bumbling because they you know there's
no crime in the town and everything
and one of the central conflicts is that
the main character
john marshall is he's like a police
officer but his dad
is the sheriff and his dad is played by
robert forster the legendary
robert forester i believe this was his
last movie because he died like not too
long after this uh
he died not too long ago so his dad is
the sheriff but doesn't even though he's
sick he doesn't really want to retire so
there's kind of like some [ __ ] going on
there
and uh so then all of these women start
turning up dead
and horribly mutilated like the first um
the first casualty is that couple that's
up there on vacation right they're like
at a cabin and then like the woman gets
all torn up
and so they're trying to figure out who
is doing this whether it's a werewolf or
whether it's a serial killer
or whatever and it's just funny because
none of the cops really have any idea
like how to really i mean you know they
can do cop stuff but they're not really
used to
doing anything like this because it's
like this tiny little town
and also john marshall uh
you know the the officer kind of in
charge of it whose dad is the sheriff
he's um he's been sober for i
think i've read a review and it said
three years but i thought i thought he
said six years he'd been sober for six
years because he used to be an alcoholic
and uh as the investigation goes on and
they can't catch this person and like
more women
start ending up uh mutilated he start he
kind of falls off
the wagon and starts drinking again and
starts um having some anger issues which
are actually really really funny
but it's just like i don't know there
was just something really really
appealing about this movie it's it's
really it's um
the pacing was really good it was only
83 minutes
um it didn't really have like a lot of
uh
you know slack time in it there wasn't
but they still like did a lot of good
with
um all the characters they were really
good at like drawing all the characters
all the relationships between the
characters
um you can really see because jim
cummings has said
i saw a little bit of an interview with
him about the movie and he was saying
how big a fan he was of david fincher's
movies
and if you watch this movie in that
context you can really see because it's
almost
it's shot like a police procedural would
be like a david fincher movie would be
but it's
a comedy like with a werewolf in it now
i don't really want to spoil the ending
um but because i think everybody should
see this we rented it on amazon prime
yeah i think it was 5.99
and i think it hasn't been out that long
i think it only came out last october
but it's definitely worth seeing it's
like i had it on my list because
i kept seeing it turn up because every
now and then i'll periodically go in and
like look at all the
horror blogs and say you know what were
their favorite movies from 2020
and this came up on a lot of people's
lists and i was like well [ __ ] man i got
that sounds good so i got to write it
down and watch it and it's like really
really funny oh also
ricky lindholm is in this like she's one
of the cops too
i know she's been in like [ __ ] tons of
other stuff but to me she will always be
one half of garfunkel and oates
um if you don't know garfunkel and oats
go right now
and find them on youtube there it's a
it's a duo and they write
like parody songs and they are just i
mean
pants pissingly funny those those two
ladies
they're just funny funny funny as well i
think my one of my uh
favorite one of my favorite songs of
theirs well pregnant women are smug is
really funny
and also they did one called the
loophole
about how girls in catholic schools
could still say they were virgins if you
only [ __ ] him in the butt
you know what i mean so it's like so
it's songs like that they're real
they're definitely not safe for work so
don't like blast like get your office or
anything
but uh yeah they're super funny but
she's in this as well
but yeah i just i really really liked
this movie a lot i just i thought it was
really entertaining
it was really funny if like i said if
you really like that quirky like coen
brothers
fargo type of humor then you would
probably really dig this i think because
i i watched like a lot of other horror
movie reviews of it and a lot of people
really seem to like it
yeah you know i i wasn't i didn't really
like it you didn't like it
of course you didn't
[Laughter]
okay well if you like if you like uh
werewolf movies then you probably
wouldn't like it
if you like scooby doo you'd probably
like it but
no not them it's a competent movie
it is funny is this a werewolf movie no
no well it's a comedy yeah
with werewolf trappings yeah yeah
that's all just approach it like that it
does have horror movie aspects like i
said it's got like a lot of gore in it
um you know a lot of the bodies and
stuff like that it's real
you know gory but it's it's more a
comedy than a horror movie and it
focuses a lot it's
it's almost kind of like a character
study of
the cop like kind of unraveling and like
losing his mind like
it could have been i give it i give i
give it i give it this much
this could have been an excellent
werewolf movie but it isn't
it it didn't do it that's all i got to
say about it it is a good movie
yeah it's not a good werewolf movie yeah
but like i said that's
it could have been but it is yeah like i
said don't go into it for
it is kind of a werewolf movie but kind
of not yeah so just go into it like as
just approach it like a horror comedy
like a quirky horror comedy
um but the fact that they made this for
so little budget and this is only like
his second movie
i don't know i just i just thought it
was really really fun i was like i just
thought it was [ __ ] hilarious like
some of the scenes were [ __ ]
hilarious it's very it's very dark
humor like i said in just real dark
quirky humor and a lot of it kind of
comes from
it a lot of it comes from jim cummings
character just like losing his [ __ ]
marbles and like being drunk and like
losing his memory and [ __ ] like that and
blacking out
and punching people and just like all
this stuff because he's so frustrated
with what the [ __ ] is going on because
he's got some other family [ __ ] going on
too not just with his dad
this could have almost been like ginger
snaps but it wasn't
it's a yeah it's a different yeah i
don't know
similar but it's kind of like it's not
really it wasn't really going for the
same thing i guess ginger snaps was kind
of funny too but it wasn't really
but it was a word portrayed as a comedy
yeah yeah yeah and that's why you know i
would much rather between the two i mean
i [ __ ]
picked ginger snaps over it about a
dozen times
that's way i would have gone if you're
gonna go ahead and make this movie go
ahead and do what gingersnaps did
well gingersnaps already did that though
you know what i mean but yeah you're not
making sense though
i don't want to spoil the movie but you
know what i mean just uh no
no they didn't deliver yeah okay they
didn't deliver i mean i can see what
you're saying
but i don't if you're gonna do that then
do it
but i just i don't know i kind of like
how it came out how it turned out
like i said it was it's it's kind of
like i said it's hard to it's hard to
say without spoiling the end of it and i
don't really want to do that because
this
movie's pretty nail yeah but i don't
know i really dug it i thought it was
really entertaining but like i said
you know it's more a comedy than a
horror movie yeah but it is very
gory so yeah don't think it's not going
to be gory because it is gory
but uh yeah oh yeah that's right pat
hatfield said uh ricky lindholm was in
another horror comedy called hell baby i
actually saw that i really liked that
movie a lot
and i just um i don't hear a lot of
people like talking about it weirdly
i thought it was like really funny i
actually should watch it again i think
it might be on
i think it was on to be so it might be
it might be free to watch but i remember
seeing it somewhere it was on netflix i
don't know i remember watching it like
randomly because it uh
just looked funny but yeah i'd forgotten
she was in that because i know i've seen
her everywhere
um but i just remembered her from uh you
know
garfunkel and oates but i know i looked
at her imdb real quick and yeah she's
been in a [ __ ]
[ __ ] ton of stuff uh you know so that's
why she's familiar
but um yeah so like i said unless you're
unless you're cranky like tom
in the comments section does it have a
scooby-doo ending
yeah yeah of course it does well sort of
i guess sort of
sort of that's like it's like
it's like it's like making a porn movie
but there's no sex in it
you know it's equivalent well then it's
not a porn and it's not a porn movie so
it's like if it's a werewolf movie
there's no werewolf in it then [ __ ]
it's not a world movie
well there's it does it's not listed as
a werewolf movie it's listed as
a horror comedy that's what it's making
you think it is well so
it's like oh man
he just wants to be contrarian no it's
not what it is
it would just be disappointing if that's
what i that's kind of what i was
expecting but
you know let's put it this way my
expectations were what do they call it
subverted subverting your expectations
yeah
yeah so and tom does not like that
[ __ ] no [ __ ] no i don't mind it that's
like
i don't like like you're gonna blow me
right but then the last minute no i'm
not gonna blow you
you know isn't that hot no get the [ __ ]
out of here
i don't know it's not really the same
thing i don't know yeah it is well
in art i don't i don't really expect um
you know everything to just be the same
and be like well that turned out exactly
the way i expected i don't i don't
usually i don't really like that like i
understand this
that that that they're like
there is an artistic quality to film
all right but film is not art it's it's
just
it is it's a business venture there are
people throwing money together to make
these things and then they have to go
and go to the damn theater and [ __ ]
make profit they want to
they want to increase their investment
by about 300 percent
so you know when you start getting
involved with these
uh you know [ __ ] director auteurs and
[ __ ] like that you're just going to lose
your [ __ ] money
you know if you're going to make a movie
this shit's got to deliver
if you're going to have an action movie
the shit's going to have a whole bunch
of guns in it a bunch of explosions and
[ __ ]
a boss fight at the end and you know
that hey you know [ __ ] car wrecks
that's an action movie
you can't have an action movie and then
just have a bunch of [ __ ] jerk-offs
sitting around talking
that's like the [ __ ] that they do in the
50s let's just sit in offices we'll call
each other on the phone
and discuss action it doesn't work
that's mad wood [ __ ] it just doesn't
work well that they did that because of
budget constraints
right they couldn't show the monster all
the time right so they had to pat out
there
right well if you're going to have a
monster movie have a [ __ ] monster
there is there is a monster in this
whatever
i'm just saying yeah i'm not really i
mean obviously you're
you know it no no no obviously not
everybody like has your point of view
because this got like you know 90
good reviews and like i said all the
horror channels that i saw like they
they all loved it so so they don't go
into things
i just go into a movie like expecting an
entertaining movie i don't
i don't get mad if it doesn't go the way
i think it should go yeah i'm just
because i didn't make the movie i'm just
gonna make my face i'm just gonna make
you're gonna make your face
his little his little cranky pants face
he's getting fussy
[Laughter]
what's that face on your face that's my
face on my face that's what we always
say to pookie when she looks at us funny
like if we do if
we do something crazy and she looks at
us i'm like what's that face on your
face
all right so are you done being being
crabby
i'm not crabby i'm just being i'm i'm
being correct
no i don't think you are but okay who's
gonna be making the food tonight
i already ate you're gonna you already
okay
i hate while you're at the grocery store
okay i don't have time to [ __ ] around
wait
[Laughter]
yeah i think you know what we're okay so
we're gonna do the party stream tomorrow
night right on wednesday it's tuesday
right yeah yeah okay
so yeah tomorrow night will be the party
stream so we don't have to you know what
i kind of want to watch
i don't know if i'll be able to stay
awake for the whole thing because i'm
really sleepy
but i think that didn't netflix just add
like a mini serie like a crime mini
series about like all those
mormon murders like all this you know
what i mean yeah
i think i might want to watch that what
was he saying i needed that
yeah he does he always needs a nap
[Laughter]
gonna i'm gonna put him to put him down
in this crib and like get him get him
get his little pacifier
i like [ __ ] with you it's just it's
so easy no it's not
it's so easy because you just get all
like
you know what i mean tom needs a nap
says i always say don't give me that
tone of face oh that's a good one too i
never heard that one
but yeah we always say that to pokey
it's like with that face on your face
because she has like crazy facial
expressions when we do something that
she does like if we don't let her
go outside or something she looks at us
like are you [ __ ] kidding me she
couldn't see that face with a big with
big
eyes like that yeah she definitely does
have are you [ __ ] kidding
me face yeah beijing does too although
it looks a little bit different
beijing's is a lot more regal i guess
because she just like stares at you like
i can [ __ ] kill you right now
that's what she looks like all right so
we will be back tomorrow night at 5 00
p.m eastern standard time
and remember if you're somewhere where
they haven't done uh
daylight savings yet it might be all
kind of
i don't even know what to tell you i
don't know what i don't know what time
it's going to be
but it'll be uh 5 p.m est daylight
standard
time yeah so you guys can figure out
what time that's going to be
for tomorrow night i have no idea what
we're going to be talking about maybe
talk about that mormon thing if we
watch it or whatever the [ __ ] we end up
watching or whatever i might pick on tom
some more
about being cranky
oh [ __ ] we have the same shirt on again
oh [ __ ] we should do
whoops i only just noticed yeah we're so
matchy-matchy i usually like try not to
do that but
it's so good because sometimes he comes
in he's like what shirt do you have on
i gotta go change yeah tammy says
nice chat everyone catch you all
tomorrow drunk or sober or sober working
on getting drunk yep it'll be there
yeah sober working on getting drunk got
pretty drunk last night
stop feeling good though i didn't i felt
yeah it was all right yeah i felt okay
today went to that damn mcdonald's
drive-through on the way back
i got a [ __ ] big mac and a quarter
pounder with bacon on it of course you
did
well here's the shape of meals i just
got sam well here's the shitty thing
it's like
[ __ ] yeah go tell them what we wanted
yeah right well okay
um we don't usually like eat at
mcdonald's very much
but you know when we're drunk and stuff
i hadn't really eaten much
during the day so i was like pretty
hungry and there's a mcdonald's like
right
around the corner from our house and
it's open all night so we usually stop
there like right on the way home
we the whole time we were at the bar
like the last half an hour yeah
i was like man i know this is gross but
i really kind of want to fillet a fish
yeah and they have that double one now
like with the two patties
two patties on it yeah yeah that's nice
that sandwich should have been well yeah
because like i said they usually go too
heavy on the tartar sauce but if it had
like two big thick
thick things of fish on it that would be
a lot better so so we were like all
pumped about it we're like oh man we're
gonna get the double fish sandwich yeah
yeah
then we go through the drive-through and
it's not on the menu and he says to the
girl of the widow he's like
don't tell me that you don't have the
double fish sandwich she's like well we
do
we do still have it but she's like we
have limited menu after midnight i knew
they didn't do breakfast after midnight
anymore because we used to
when we come back from tomorrow we'd
always get like up to the wind we'd
always get like a yeah
i pulled up to the gym don't tell me you
don't have that sandwich
yeah no we don't have it right yeah
she's like we usually have it but they
have a limited menu after midnight which
i they've been doing that for a long
time because remember
for a while we were getting breakfast
because i was so [ __ ] excited that
they started doing breakfast like
limited breakfast like 24 hours yeah i'd
get like three eggman muffins
well i would just get a sausage egg
muffin and a coffee but um
you know what i mean so they did they
stopped doing that and then they don't
have any of the fish i guess because a
lot of people don't order it especially
like it's monday night it's like two
o'clock in the morning no one's gonna
order a [ __ ] fish sandwich except for
me
[Laughter]
but they didn't even have that so i was
like well [ __ ] i just got a quarter
pounder instead
it was still good in coffee it doesn't
matter with me i can eat anything now
well good for you yes yes she's getting
jealous these injections i can eat
anything
i've never been able to eat anything
i've always i've always had horrible
digestion i also don't have that damn
indigestion or any of that
acid reflux all that [ __ ] went away
yeah just lucky just yeah feel that body
pull that [ __ ] testosterone
and that that might be i don't want that
might be there that might be that
pituitary gland
[ __ ] drug that i'm just he wants me
to grow a beard i guess
i don't know what the [ __ ] she's talking
about he wants me to take that
he wants me to take that i never said
that where are you getting this
what you're saying like a test they got
another check
they've got all kinds of other [ __ ] that
they give they're giving to women at
that clinic
all kinds of weight loss stuff all kinds
of things international [ __ ]
[ __ ] um bringing back [ __ ]
women's [ __ ] uh damn
egg production and [ __ ] ovulation the
ovulating [ __ ] is ovulating over there
is ovulating
[Laughter]
she's like 60 years old having babies
and [ __ ] i don't know if that's such a
good idea
[Laughter]
she's like well here's a baby
somebody'll take care of it right now
check it out i mean you know it's like i
can't see because once you get that old
you're like so [ __ ] past
it yeah all the [ __ ] it's like i
don't even know if you can keep that's
like why would you want to put up with a
kid at that age [ __ ] no but all those
all those celebrities they're all on
hormone therapies
yeah they all are uh louis did you guys
watch that cecil hotel documentary on
netflix yeah we did did we review it i
thought we did
yeah yeah because it was about a lisa
lamb and it was kind of about yeah i
think we reviewed it
and then uh fido says i'm sorry sir we
don't have the filet of fish and the ice
cream machine
is always out of order you know what
it's um i had a brother that used to
work at mcdonald's and
i had a friend that worked at mcdonald's
they said a lot of times the ice cream
machine or the milkshake machine isn't
broken
it's just that it's a pain in the ass to
clean it
so especially if it's like close to when
it's going to close and they've already
cleaned it there's like yeah it's broken
so they don't have to clean it again
that says he's always got that acid
reflux i'm telling you man
that [ __ ] hormone therapy [ __ ]
dollar for dollar that's the way
it goes because it replaces all those
other little [ __ ]
age-related treatments that they give
you their acid reflux
[ __ ] it treats [ __ ] diabetes
[ __ ] all that all that damn
[ __ ] skin care because you start
[ __ ] getting real moist skin again
dick pills you don't need dick pills all
that [ __ ] they're losing money
on all that that's why they don't want
you insurance won't cover
uh trt or hrt because they know that it
[ __ ]
it solves too many goddamn problems and
they're not in there and they'd lose
money
because they're making money off those
other little secondary treatments
it's [ __ ] scabs all this [ __ ] scams
man
you [ __ ] get old when you get old
your endocrine system stops producing
the [ __ ] that it needs
put it back in there you'll feel a lot
better
you'll feel a lot better put it back in
there it belongs in there
had a [ __ ] bartender says but when
you get old it's supposed to go
no it's not it is not supposed to go
down you're not even supposed to die
that's an error you're not supposed to
die and you're not supposed to age
that's not programmed in there they've
been guys have been [ __ ] looking at
that for [ __ ] decades going you know
what
you're not really supposed to age this
is an error
you know yeah you're not they got they
can they'll pull the damn they don't
know how long a [ __ ]
alligator lives they don't
they just get bigger and bigger and
bigger until they can't feed themselves
they can't get enough food and a [ __ ]
130 year damn
130 year old alligator is every bit as
spry
and healthy as a [ __ ] 30 day year old
alligator they don't age they just get
bigger
they don't get it yeah i'm glad that
doesn't happen to people yeah
they don't get i don't age i just get
bigger they get bigger pretty soon i'm
going to be
big enough to eat the empire there's no
sign
no sign of any aging in an alligator or
a shark
with some wild [ __ ] they don't ever get
cancer which that's a clue right there
eventually they'll go in there with
those damn [ __ ] genetic engineering
and they'll fix that
they'll fix all that i think that's a
myth that sharks don't get cancer
no i don't think they do because i don't
think uh um
because i remember that was kind of like
a thing that was misinterpreted a lot
back in the 90s and might be another way
of
describing that but uh evidently
alligators and turtles don't get it the
turtle can live to be about 150 years
old too
yeah they live a long time long long
time although a turtle slows down a
little bit
but not an hour they're pretty slow to
start with yeah i think maybe that's the
secret of their longevity because they
just like moving slow
moving slow and they just hang around
not worrying about anything they got a
big shell on
i got my whole house right here i'll
never be homeless but not a house just
bird around
eating lettuce not out alligators don't
gets
don't get slow yeah in fact they don't
know
and i've heard this many times that they
don't know how long an alligator lives
they've never seen one die of old age
i'd have to look they've seen him
starve to death because the owner
[ __ ] died and didn't feed it and it
was already 13
40 years old you know and they found
skeletons or fossils of [ __ ]
alligators that are twice as big as the
biggest ones
now you know and they think that that
might be the same alligator pretty much
it's just that maybe that's a two or
three hundred year old alligator
imagine that yeah it could be and
an alligator could never live to that
age in the modern world somebody kill it
they go look at that big alligator shoot
it that's what would happen
well yeah and there may not be a big
enough food for it to eat anymore
because those things got that big back
in a time when everything was big
it's a lot of food well one if one got
that big around here they'd just start
eating people
and then they'd have to kill it yeah
well they'd kill it before that if it
started eating people's pets and [ __ ]
like that
yeah because they get big and they get
hungry
and they gotta [ __ ] get a lot of
people thinking i'm hungry yeah
sorry i just imagine something when you
get that big you can have a [ __ ] big
food requirement
per day so you're going to be out there
going i got to eat some [ __ ] well
because the big body has like yeah
they burn more calories you spend more
calories so you need more calories in
yeah but yeah all right so uh we'll be
back
tomorrow evening at 5 p.m eastern
standard time daylight savings time all
that kind of [ __ ] that i said earlier
for our party stream we'll figure have a
drink and
talk about some fun [ __ ] you know all
right so uh thanks everybody for
dropping by sorry we were a little late
today but you know better late than
never i guess
we'll see you guys tomorrow bye